Magic moments happen when
your app does something so
that your user won't have to, like
figuring out their location for them, so
they don't have to type on
that tiny little keyboard.
In Sunshine we ask the user for
their location, but
the Google Maps platform provides
location services that could
allow us to get
a location automatically.
The Places API was released
earlier this year and
includes a variety of
helpful location services.
For example,
the auto complete API offers your
users the power of
predictive auto complete for
places with a user experience
similar to the Google search box.
You can also get the user's current
location, get a place by ID and
even add a place to
the Google Places database.
But for Sunshine, we're going to use the
Place Picker because it provides a UI
dialogue that displays an interactive
map, and a list of nearby places,
from geographical addresses
to local businesses.
Users can then choose a place
that is passed back to your app.
You could always develop your
own location widget, but
there are several advantages
to using the Place Picker.
First and foremost, the user experience
will be consistent with other apps using
the Place Picker, including both
Google apps and third-party ones.
This means your users will likely
already know how to interact
with this widget.
Second, accessibility is built in, and
you should already know
how important that is.
But finally,
it saves you development time so
that you can focus your efforts on
the features you care the most about.